This past week, former
Vice President
Mike Pence
testified more than 5 hours
before a federal grand jury
investigating the aftermath of
2020 election
is the highest
ranking government official
to take part in special counsel
Jack Smith's investigation
and conservative lawyer George Conway
joins us to talk about this.
George great to see you as always.
What do you think I mean,
what is your sense of Pence
spending 5 hours
before this federal grand jury.
I mean you
you know how some of these cases
may play out.
Could it have been
just I'm not commenting.
I take the Fifth the whole time.
This sounds as though he did offer
some information.
Yeah, I doubt he did that for 5 hours.
Not answering questions.
I mean, it was litigated
all the way up to the US Court of Appeals
in the District of Columbia Circuit.
And it's clear that he had testimony
to give.
It's just a remarkable thing
historically as well,
because I don't think
I don't think
we've ever seen a circumstance
where a vice president
a former vice
president, is being called to testify
before a federal grand jury
in a criminal investigation
against the former
president under which he served
it simply a remarkable thing.
And obviously
the court of Appeals rejected.
Given what we can see from
from the sealed from the docket,
although most of all,
the papers are sealed
and the opinion is,
you know,
it's pretty clear the court of Appeals
rejected any effort
by Trump to block the testimony.
And I think I hope
that that Mike Pence
was cooperative and testified.
So all his conversations,
which with the president,
which aren't subject
to executive privilege
because they weren't
in furtherance of Trump's
executive duties,
they were actually interrogation
of his duty
to support and defend the Constitution
You know,
I want to ask you about some of the other
legal issues facing the former president.
But I have to ask you about this.
Your Trump was photographed
this past week
hugging a woman who was sentenced to jail
for rioting at the Capitol
on January six,
calling for Pence to be executed.
You know, he continues.
Trump continues to escalate his support
for people charged in the Capitol riot.
He's talked about pardoning some of them.
What was your reaction to that
when you saw that?
Well, I'm really at a loss for words
whenever he does things like this,
because it's just continually
you think he's reached the bottom And yet
he seems somehow to dig himself
deeper into the muck.
I mean, this is just
an absolute positive disgrace.
He signed the woman's backpack
like it was some kind of souvenir,
the backpack
she took to the insurrection
at the Capitol.
He's clean, he's promising.
He's been promising for months.
That he's going to pardon
all these people, these people,
hundreds of people who committed,
you know,
real crimes
that they're being convicted for
and being sentenced for
in the District of Columbia.
In the federal courts there.
It's a complete
and utter disgrace and a disgrace
that anybody could support a man
who was who who swore an oath
to preserve, protect
and defend the Constitution,
the United States, who was the chief
law enforcement officer
in the United States, in effect,
because he's charged with executing
the laws
at praising
and and rewarding and promising to help
these people
who basically tried
to stop the peaceful transfer of power.
It is
it is beyond disgraceful
and it is beyond disgraceful
that more Republicans
don't call him out for this.
And I I'm just at a loss for words
that really adequately capture
how how disgusting this all is.
And let me ask you about
what's been happening down in Georgia,
because it sounds like
we might be reaching
some sort of resolution soon
for the Fulton County District Attorney,
Fani Willis.
Apparently,
she plans to announce this summer
whether she will bring Racketeer
and conspiracy charges against former
President Donald Trump,
allies of his for their attempts
to overturn Georgia's 2020
election results.
And apparently now
one of Georgia's
so-called fake electors is joining
Trump in this motion to
get rid of the special grand
jury or quash the grand jury report.
What are your thoughts on that
Georgia case?
Is there some peril for Trump potentially
in this Georgia case? Or does he.
Does he have to worry
more about what
the special counsel is
doing here in Washington?
Well, I think he has to worry
about what
the special counsel
is doing in Washington and worry
a great deal about Tiffany Willis
Fulton County investigation.
I mean, remember, there he is
caught on tape essentially
trying to coerce the secretary of state
of the state of Georgia
into finding
precisely the number of votes
he needed to win the election.
He you know, he
he participated,
I think the January six committee
evidence showed in a
very broad conspiracy
to have people fraudulently submit fake
electoral votes
to the Congress of the United States.
And those fake electors.
You know, apparently
some of them are are appear to be based
on some of the papers that have been
filed in court. Testifying,
giving helpful testimony
to the prosecutors.
And this is going to be a very, very,
very significant case. And then all.
And there was this other development
where MS.
Willis,
who wrote a letter to local
law enforcement
authorities telling them that, you know,
be prepared
for something to happen
between the June, July 11,
I think in September.
First, I don't remember the precise dates
which coincide with when
a grand jury
could return an indictment in that case.
And it's pretty clear
you would not send that letter
saying, you know, b, b, b, b, b, be
prepared for civil disorder.
If it was just Rudy Giuliani or
or Mark Meadows
who was going to be in the dock.
Let me ask you about the
Jean Carroll case in New York.
The writer who accuses Trump
of raping her back in the mid 1990s,
she faced two days of very aggressive
questioning from Trump's
attorney, Joe Tacopina.
I want to ask you about something.
Apparently, George,
you and I have talked about this
in the past that you urged
Jean Carroll
to get an attorney in the first place.
When I guess this was something
that was relayed to you.
Can you tell us about that?
Yeah.
What do you think
the outcome of this case might be?
Well, I'll it's a pretty simple story.
I mean, after
Jean Carroll
came forward with her allegations, I,
I wrote a, an op ed piece
in The Washington Post
basically pointing out
that all of the Republicans who supported
the charges
that wanted to Broderick
had made against Bill Clinton
back in the nineties
should be equally concerned about
and if not more concerned about
the charges
that Jean Carroll
had made against Donald Trump,
because there was actually
corroboration by
contemporaneous witnesses who
Jean Carroll told the story to
within days of of of it happening.
And it just so happened
that I think the week after
I wrote that op ed,
I attended a party in in Manhattan,
just the just the dinner party
where Jean Carroll was a guest.
And she walked up to me
and introduced herself.
And I think she thanked me
for the piece that I had written.
And somehow or other
she mentioned that, you know,
she had been kicking around the idea
of the possibility
of bringing a lawsuit
or some people were suggesting it to her.
And I gave it about a millisecond worth
of thought and said, well,
there's a
there's a potential defamation claim.
There is a fact
there could be a substantial defamation
claim there,
because if he's lying about you by saying
that you are lying,
that is that is defamatory.
So and I said it
probably would make sense
if you are have any interest
in pursuing this,
you probably should
you should you should consult counsel.
And then a moment later,
it popped into my head.
Who that who that lawyer ought to be
who the right lawyer would be.
A woman named Robby Kaplan,
who was a good friend of mine,
who is famous for having litigated
the Defense of Marriage Act case
and having won it in the Supreme Court.
She's just a tremendously
talented litigator.
And I just thought, well,
no one is going to give me,
Carol, better advice
than than Robby Kaplan
and no one's going to be able
to suss out the details of this case
and figure out
whether it's a case
that should be brought in Robby.
And the next day,
I somehow I connected them together
and and then the next months
later, apparently, you know,
they determined to bring suit
and they did.
And you think this is where we are today
and you think this this could be serious?
Trouble for Donald Trump?
It could be.
I mean, you know, look,
I don't want to predict what
juries will do.
I believe Eugene Carol.
I believe it I've gotten to know her.
I think she's a truthful
and wonderful person, the kind person.
She's somebody who doesn't say amnesty
now has doesn't have a nasty word
to say about anybody.
And I find particularly compelling,
as in the other MeToo cases, the fact
that two in-depth bonded people test
will testify that Jean Carole King,
Jean Carroll told me this story
about what happened at the
at the department store,
you know, within to within a day or two
after it happened.
I mean, that's always been
I mean, if you've read the work
of of of Broman and Farrow in the
in The New Yorker
and Jodi Kantor in The New York Times,
those are that
that kind of evidence
is extremely important in establishing
something that would otherwise be
he said he said versus she said.
In addition,
the pattern evidence is very,
very substantial here.
I mean,
the number of women who have come forward
with allegations of Donald Trump
that are very, very similar
and they're going to be
the judge has admitted
has already held that under rule
for 15 of the federal rules of evidence.
Two of those victims
who had similar incidents occur to them
will be allowed to testify,
including another woman
who I got to know who I also think
is just going to be a tremendously
wonderful witness
Natasha Stoynoff
who was was assaulted by Trump at Mar
a Lago
when she was trying to do a
magazine report for People magazine
on on the then mogul not yet president.
We'll see how these allegations
play out in this case George Conway,
thanks so much for your time again.
We appreciate it. Good talking to you.
Thank you.